I the undersigned Jani berry the acting
returning officer for Darby North
constituency hereby publish and declare
that the total number of votes given for
each candidate by the said election is
as follows
Lucy Helen care Liberal Democrat 2262
William George
Kitson Piper you Kip 1181 Amanda James
Holloway the Conservative Party
candidate 20 1607 Christopher Williamson
Labour Party 23,000 6
Williamson Parliament I also hereby
published anding where that the number
of ballot paper was rejected and not
counted by me is as follows
wonderful fishel mark zero voting for
more than one candidate 21 writing or
martin by which a voter could be
identifying you two unmarked or wholly
void and certain cat6 thank you well
thank you very much indeed
i had hope that I'll be able to speak
directly to our supporters but I'm
afraid you'll have to make do with a
disembodied voice but can I first of all
offer my commiserations to amanda
solloway and thank the counters who have
not been hard to stay up quite as late
as they did last time in 2015 I also
want to pay tribute to the Green Party
for stepping aside and making a reality
of the Progressive Alliance here in
Darby north and it's in no small measure
to their decision to step down but has
helped us to win this seat for labour
this evening I also want to there are so
many people I want to thank but there
are some special people that I must make
mention of first of whom is Sarah
Russell who's been absolutely
outstanding as the coordinator of this
campaign under the tutelage of course of
the agent Josiah's I also want to
I also wanted to thank my inner circle
who have been absolutely fantastic and
stood with me throughout and have been a
tower of strength and I'm very very
grateful for their effort because this
victory isn't mine it's theirs and it's
all the labour party members and our
supporters but I should also mention
Jyothi Wilkinson who's been brilliant
Peter Davis who's been also outstanding
mr. O Brien has also been a wonderful
tower of strength as has been Bellamy
boomer Umar Cosme and of course Lois
Bassett they will go down in the annals
of Dobie North labor movement history
for this historic victory this evening I
also want to thank the party members who
have done a brilliant job in actually
providing huge support that's made this
victory possible a momentum have been
absolutely outstanding in their support
we've had on occasions over a hundred
and fifty people on the street and 20
teams on occasions have been canvassing
for the Labour Party in Diaby north as
if after all is someone else who I
should also mention has been fantastic
in actually making sure that we get
people to the polling station and the
final person I want to thank is Sarah a
bhoot AG who also known as the meme we
she set up the a it was called the Chris
Williamson's
means for Darby north team and she's
been absolutely brilliant in her
campaign so this victory belongs to all
of them and particularly the young
people who were inspired by Jeremy
Corbyn and his policy agenda
this is been the best campaign in my 41
years as a member of the Labour Party
and to all those pundits who said that
Jeremy Corbyn was unelectable well they
should be eating their words because it
looks like labour is on course under
Jeremy Corbyn to what perform Tony Blair
in 2005 in terms of the share of the
vote Tony Blair in 2000 fried Gordon
Brown in 2010 ed Miliband in 2015 and of
course Michael foot in 1983 and Neil
connect in 1987 and 1992 this victory is
jeremy corbyn's victory so let's all get
behind Jeremy Corbyn it seems now very
clear that the compass is pointing in
the Labour Party's direction we proved
the pundits wrong the despicable smears
the gutter press particularly the son
the mail and the Express have all been
proved wrong and that vinícius headline
that Tom Newton done was responsible for
in the Sun I think he should frankly
consider his position and resign but
it's been an incredible privilege to be
reelected to represent my home city
labour offered a message of hope in this
election this manifesto for the many not
the few it's the best manifesto that the
Labour Party has produced since 1945 and
people have rejected peers and smears
the fears and smears of the Tories in
favour of a message of hope they want an
economy that works for ordinary people
they want to maintain pensions and the
winter fuel allowance and they've
rejected the disgraceful proposition of
a dementia tax they want to reverse the
cuts and the privatization they want to
invest in child care and education and
abolish tuition fees people have voted
against the attacks on people who are
living in poverty and they voted in
favor of a 10 pound minimum wage
and to reverse the ante trade union
legislation what this has proven to me
is that this movement will continue to
grow who would have thought the Labour
Party would now have six hundred and
sixty thousand members just a couple of
short years ago we will continue to
build this movement and in the words of
Keir Hardie will continue to work to
deliver the sunshine of socialism thank
you
[Applause]